I just want to introduce our next our
next panelist who I I suspect everyone
in this this room knows or a knows about
John welcome John holywell is a CFR
senior fellow and co-director of CFR's
program in social interactions identity
and well-being he is one of the world's
leading researchers into the social and
the economic components of happiness and
he's a pioneer in incorporating
well-being into economic models and
we're so proud of him in this city for
doing that aren't we he is co-editor of
the world happiness report 2015 which
will be released in New York City in a
couple of days on April the 23rd dr.
Halliwell John is also professor
emeritus of economics at the Vancouver
school of economics at UBC and probably
if you turned on your radio or
television or Twitter feed or whatever
today you would realize that he's in
high demand today as a result of the
study that was recently released but I
think he's in high demand generally and
he is getting ready to release the world
happiness report in New York on 30
thursday so John welcome please welcome
John hello
thank you thank you I'll I my audible
credible you want the evidence first I
want to run little experiment first are
you happy some of you know how to run
the rest of the experiment I'll just see
whether you all do or not if you're
happy and you know it clap your hands if
you're happy and you know you don't the
experienced audience knows that the
experiment is not complete until we've
all sung the song and clapped our hands
together with me if you're happy and you
know it clap your hands if you're happy
and you know it clap your hands if
you're happy and you know what and you
really want to show it if you're happy
and you know it clap your hands now my
colleagues have given away most of the
answers that I'm about to give you but
the next question is are you happier now
than you were two minutes ago and
generally answer that question is yes
it's certainly not my singing voice it's
because we were singing together and
it's that mayor of fact there's lots of
lab experiments showing precisely that
the second point of that experiment is
to say that's a very specific definition
of happiness you know exactly what i was
asking and you knew how to answer it
this was the emotional definition of
happiness which was already talked about
the kind of happiness that we're going
to be discussing in most of the rest of
our time here is a relational form of
cognitive forms that are you happy with
your life as a whole you're using your
mind in a quite different way and you
don't just it's not how I'm feeling at
the moment it's I think about my life as
a whole and come back with the answers
some people have used the fact that
these two different definitions of
happiness are different to pooh-pooh the
whole business fortunately these two
definitions when asked to people they
know exactly the conversational context
in which there
then they give the right answers so the
answers to the relational question come
back with a strong dependence on life
circumstances the happiness ones comes
back the emotional ones come back with a
strong dependence on whether they've
just song a silly children's song see if
that changed your whole life view then
you'd worry about the nature of the
question for that your life view you're
with me so those two things are very
different and they mutually supportive
not antagonistic second point I want to
make quite different from the first is
that I'm very happy to be here and for
two reasons one see that wonderful
colleagues we get to work with and
second to celebrate and thank see far
for the being able to meet this possible
they're too nice links with see far
first see far has supported all the
research that made this possible I say
with some truth the world happiness
report simply wouldn't exist in anything
like the form it had had see far not
been on the scene as one of its sponsors
Morse most specifically through our
research the second is that we in the
social interactions program who are
major beneficiaries of this
collaborative research live off it in
two ways one it has enabled us to build
an interdisciplinary program you imagine
studying happiness if you came from one
discipline right you couldn't possibly
do it right and you certainly couldn't
done the view started from economics and
only we're using what you learned in
economics so we have in our program
psychologist political scientist
epidemiologist you name it people who
are able to drop their egos at the door
come in and work together for 10 years
right doesn't you don't learn how to do
this overnight and are then able to do
this now you may have heard of see far
2.0 the notion of what we're building
see far as building in the future is
going beyond the fundamental research
that was in all these programs initially
and saying you know if we're really
going to change the way knowledge
changes and changes the world we've got
two more elements we want to add one is
reaching a broad in order to make
international connections and learn from
others and help them and the other is to
make connections with the community so
that we can make lengths between the
dynamic research and what's done in
practice so you can see how the partners
involved in this panel represent our
attempt within this program to do
precisely that but what are we missing
in this panel what we're missing is
what's in the audience because quite
specifically we invited some
deliberately and some just hoping you'd
come people who care about this city and
care a lot about it and have a variety
of rich experiences about how you can
make life in a big city better now now
that you've seen Grant's figures you
know their challenges in big cities
right all those ones at the bottom were
big cities now a number of people you
know people in the media take cameras
out into the streets and they say what
do you think of this finding from stat
Canon there's two immediate answers they
tend to get I haven't watched all the
stuff but I've seen a couple of them one
is it's a bad survey the only people who
answer happiness surveys are unhappy
people it's a especially in Vancouver I
guess you'd have to say but of course
from what you've heard from that you
know that's not the case these are
questions built into the middle of a
Canadian Community Health Survey and the
and the other one is to get cross and
saying we are not unhappy here this is a
very
this is very happy city that's a non
dashain smile I just gave you the
dashain file is the authentic smile so
the first thing I have to tell people
who were acting in either of those ways
is first of all to tell them about the
survey and then to say you know if you
took the Vancouver number and put it
into the world happiness report ranking
of countries where do you think
Vancouver would sit I'm going to put it
into the ladder from the world happiness
report 2013 because 2015 is still
embargoed but put it into the last list
where do you think Vancouver would sit
in the top doesn't of saggin a zombie in
the top one two or three so what that's
saying is and they're very tight at the
top of that distribution everyone in
Canada is pretty happy there were any of
the communities you can think of are
pretty happy we're bound in a very
narrow bomb but these are still because
of this sample of a third of a million
people we can start getting into the
fine points well the fine points is
where the data released start speaking
to you we're now saying let's talk about
different kinds of communities and then
ask how they differ and it was quite
apparent right all of all the evidence
we have marled the world is what really
makes a difference to people's lives is
three secrets to happiness the reason I
don't have a overhead is I've got three
secrets and if you put your secrets of
the overhead there they're hardly
secrets right
so don't let this get out one of them is
the vital importance of trust well it
turns out the trust is greases every
wheel that needs greasing but more
important you're really happy in an
environment where you think your wallet
will be returned the other is that the
power of generosity to make you happy as
well as to big build better communities
now that's a very new finding within the
happiness research and the psychologist
and our program have been some of the
leaders in in in doing that to research
the third one which I sort of tried to
bring a bunch of things together is the
power of collaboration so it really is
this it isn't just company it's doing
things and it's doing things together
hey back up to Aristotle right what did
aristotle say about all this because i'm
in this context my interpretation I'm an
Aristotelian of the strongest sort he
said you should do just what grant does
go out and ask people in a reflective
mood to think of their life as a whole
and come back with a scale he said you
know I think I know what would make them
happy would give a high value to that
and he listed all those factors that
showed up in Grant's equation Aristotle
was pretty good no data good insights
but then the next point he said a really
good life is then but rest on one side
by a balance of positive emotions and
here that's another it's not one of my
three secrets but it's a really
important result from this research the
presence of positives wildly more
important than the absence of negatives
if you think how we run healthcare
justice systems almost anything you want
we're busy addendum Eddie harassment
policies you name it we're busy trying
to find negatives and stop them rather
than identifying the things that can be
positive and building them and of course
in the process of stopping negative
things were stopping many more important
positive things you think of the number
of innovations that don't happen because
there's a rule that says you can't do
somebody thought there was a good idea
for that rule so looking ahead because
I'm
my time is fleeting so I'm going to make
sure you get a couple of bottom line
pieces out of this to roll back the
climate of trust reducing overhead that
is affecting so many of our institutions
abilities to innovate has got to be part
of what we think so taking risks to
promote innovation by making it easy for
people to operate it the scale I'm going
to say they should be offered operating
at and to operate successfully so that's
going to be a really important part of
the story all right so I've got ours
Aristotle with the center core I've got
supported by positive emotions which are
more important than the absence of the
negatives and the only thing I'm missing
is purpose now this comes in as a
so-called eudaimonic approach to
happiness and Aristotle said this was
his bow he had the stoic side of him and
he had the epicurean side he was in this
gold mean in the middle that the sense
of purpose is really important and the
data support every element of that so
it's really important so we're talking
now how about make cities better right
this is really what we're here today for
so the first I've got three classes of
things to be said one is individual
things quick can you do in your own life
and the other is what can we do in our
jobs and institutions and the other is
what government should be doing and of
course I'm going to be slim on all of
those because that's the audience drawn
here you've got better examples than I
have Mike had some good examples they're
drawing them from around the world the
principles we should apply in developing
these ideas is that they should be
collaborative they should be
experimental and they should be small
scale well now that those are all
liberating things right it doesn't mean
doesn't mean you got to get a cabinet to
say things can get better it means you
can start right away and it start means
having a conversation in your next
elevator ride it means smiling on the
street where you otherwise wouldn't it
means making a connection where you
otherwise wouldn't it means walking kids
to school when you otherwise would drive
them but more importantly when you
collaborate with others you then say no
it's not just me doing this let's have a
carpool
a walking pool going to school so you
then create social events where they
didn't happen at the same time you're
getting more socialized healthier kids
well you could see how you could think
of those kind of changes in almost every
day to day activity you work there are
many applications within the healthcare
system and in education and elsewhere